- Salut, vous savez ce qui se passe ?
Je tiens la caméra à la main.
Ça veut dire qu'il va se passer quelque chose de particulier.
Et aujourd'hui, je suis dans le bureau évidemment
mais je ne suis pas tout seul, il y a un pote qui est passé me voir
Y'en a peut-être qui connaissent ce pote
C'est Mehdi
Mehdi il est passé à la maison, t'étais venu me voir à la Garenne-Colombe
aussi pour le spectacle
- Oui au théâtre
c'était très bien même si vous avez l'occasion allez y c'est génial
- J'ai un pote qui fait la promo. Les 20 balles comme prévu Mehdi.
Et là on discutait et puis je pensais à la vidéo que j'ai faite aujourd'hui
Donc hier pour vous et je viens de lui proposer
Qu'on fasse une mise en application de tout ce que j'ai expliqué hier,
sur lui directement. Et tu as dit : - J'ai peur
On va pas la faire chez moi, on va la faire dans un bureau
Pour ceux qui savent et ceux qui savent pas j'ai une société avec deux autres personnes
qui s'appelle Sherlock's mind et on a des nouveaux locaux
et on va aller tourner dans les nouveaux locaux comme ça je vais vous faire visiter
Ça marche ? On vous emmène !
Attention à la déco ça peut vous piquer les yeux
Pour l'instant j'ai juste mis un Mehdi
J'ai mis un Mehdi là
Ici on a remit un Mehdi
- Il en faut toujours plusieurs par salle
Ici dans cette pièce là on a mis
- Un éléphant
- Un éléphant démonté tout à fait
Ce sont les toilettes, je pense que tout le monde est intéressé par mes toilettes
- Franchement c'est LA pièce principale du bureau
C'est Mehdi qui a refait toutes les peintures
- Ouais ouais, vraiment.Voici le pourquoi de la vidéo d'ailleurs
Il était sur youtube avant youtube. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
C'est lui qui a la chaîne avec toutes les formes bizarres et les chiffres bizarres
- Ahahah je connais pas mais ça parait bizarre rien qu'à entendre tu vois
Ah tu connais pas ? - Non du tout
Il y a une chaîne sur youtube tous les jours il y a une vidéo et la vidéo c'est toujours
avec des sons bizarres et des formes bizarres et il n'y en a pas deux identiques
- Je crois que j'avais vu ça dans un top
Et ça a toujours des titres chelou tu vois
- OK je crois que j'avais vu dans un top de je-sais-plus-qui mais je sais qu'il y a quelqu'un qui avait fait un top
des chaînes bizarres et je crois que c'était dedans
Je crois, à vérifier, parce que je dis peut-être une connerie, je crois que c'est un test
en fait pour tester les algorithmes et si tout fonctionne bien - Ah oui par youtube ! Oui ! C'est ça.
Mais tu vois ils ont mis des années à communiquer dessus, tu vois et, tout le monde disait :
"Mais c'est quoi ? C'est les illuminatis ? Un truc comme ça ?"
- C'est fou. - Et y'a des abonnés, et ça je trouve ça OUF
- Y'a des gens qui regardent ça tous les jours ? - Mais bien sûr, mais je te jure qu'il y a plus d'abonnés que sur ma chaîne
Alors écoute on va poser la caméra ici, on va se trouver un joli fond
Hier pour la vidéo des 300 abonnés je vous ai fait un récapitulatif de la manière dont vous pouvez trouver un prénom,
l'extraire de la tête de quelqu'un et si vous avez pas regardé les vidéos de cette année
et que vous avez juste regardé la vidéo d'hier vous vous dites :
"mouaaais, c'est ça, bien sûr c'est du blabla" donc on va faire le test sur Mehdi
Mehdi est-ce que t'es complice ? - Oui - Voilà, c'est la meilleure réponse - Et là on sait pas ce qu'il fallait dire
Parce que si c'était un complice il dirait non, forcément
Donc, l'idée est la suivante, je ne sais pas si tu as regardé la vidéo d'hier,
mais en temps normal non car elle est sortie aujourd'hui comme t'étais déjà chez moi
P*tain la mise en abîme du truc ! C'est ouf
J'aimerais ,s'il te plait donc que tu penses à un prénom de quelqu'un que tu connais
quelqu'un qui existe et si possible quelqu'un qui a un prénom de la culture française classique
- Ça marchera pas j'ai pas pris la culture française classique mais je pense que tu connais - OK
Donc t'as un prénom en tête et tu penses que je le connais, c'est le plus important pour moi
Il faut déjà que je détermine qui est cette personne pour toi donc tu vas me regarder dans les yeux
tu ne cherches pas à me donner d'indice
Est-ce que tu peux t'approcher un peu, un peu plus par là, on va même tricher un peu, ouais super.
Je viens de bouger Mehdi pour que vous puissiez le regarder en même temps que moi.
Tu penses à qui c'est pour toi sans chercher à me donner d'indice et moi je vais segmenter un peu
ça peut être quelqu'un de ta famille, quelqu'un de tes amis,  du travail, ok on n'est pas là, amis
famille. OK.- Je supporte pas, c'est ultra,
ma bouche qui bouge sans que j'ai rien demandé, OK, ça marche
Tu me regardes toujours dans les yeux ça peut être un homme, une femme, un homme, une femme, une fille, un garçon,
D'accord, on est plus sur quelqu'un de plus jeune, je vais dire en dessous de 30 ans, c'est correct ?
- Non
Laisse moi finir mes phrases j'allais dire "ou en dessous de 40", ah je pensais être bon
C'est toi qui est bon, tu joues au poker mec ? -Non du tout. - Ah faut y jouer alors
ok... je vais passer les dizaines
tu connais à peu près l'age de la personne?
- Oui
Donc ça peut être au dessus de 20 ans
au dessus de 30 ans
au dessus de 40 ans
au dessus de 50 ans
maintenant je vais faire l'inverse
ça peut être dans la trentaine, dans la quarantaine,
la cinquantaine, la soixantaine
ok
il y a pleins de choses à analyser
vous, vous êtes gâtés les amis
- mais je vous jure qu'on a l'impression de ne rien faire
et il nous regarde avec un grand sourire c'est ultra déstabilisant
parce qu'on sait que quand il a un grand sourire c'est qu'il a quelque chose en tête
- C'est pas faux
je vais essayer de trouver la première lettre de la personne
- Ok
- d'accord.
Tu dis stop dans ta tête quand je prononce la lettre
ça peut être A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H, I, J
K, L, M, N, O, P, Q, R, S, T, U, V, W, X, Y, Z
Moi j'ai quelque chose, que je vais noter ici, si j'ai un feutre
-Ce moment où je suis déstabilisé parce que j'ai l'impression qu'il a pas trouvé
Donc s'il trouve c'est très flippant
Je vous met la lettre à laquelle je pense
Quelle est la première lettre du prénom ? - A
-Je te déteste, tu le sais ? - Fiou, on continue
Je pense que c'est une fille, au fait, je sais plus si je l'ai dit ou pas - Non mais correct
Et je pense que c'est de ta famille - Correct
on continue
Deuxième lettre
On va faire différemment comme j'avais parlé de plusieurs méthodes, donne moi juste ton poignet
Tu es gaucher ? -Non je suis droitier - OK, non bah bras gauche ça me va bien
Tu penses juste à la lettre, c'est tout
Sens toi juste impliqué quand je dirai la lettre mais c'est tout
deuxième lettre du prénom ça peut être
A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H, I, J, K, L, M, N, j'l'ai passé
- Je déteste ça, c'est horrible
Ok, j'ai deux lettres,
Donc la suite pour moi c'est une espèce de, comment te dire, de déduction en fait
c'est ça que j'ai expliqué dans la vidéo, j'ai avoué qu'après il y avait un coup de bluff final
- T'essayes de, déjà avec les deux premières lettres t'as une bonne partie des noms qui est possible
exactement et comme j'ai la partie de la famille peut-être même la personne, le sexe, la tranche d'âge
après il y a une espèce de logique, tu vois ce que je veux dire
Est-ce que tu peux nous dire déjà à qui, par rapport à toi     - Ma grand-mère
Ta grand-mère donc on est bien deux générations au dessus
Ton prénom c'est Mehdi ce qui donne un indice culturel assez précis
J'ai une lettre, le A, j'ai peut-être la deuxième lettre
J'ai essayé de déduire le prénom, comment s'appelle ta grand-mère ?
- Aïcha
Ta grand-mère elle s'appelle Aïcha,
Et moi j'avais...AÏCHA, OUII
OUI
- Il est fort, il est fort - Ça ça te plait
Tiens, je te le laisse - Oh c'est mignon
Et c'est la fin de ce carnet puisqu'il n'a plus de feuille, hop, un carnet en moins
Tiens je t'offre le carnet qui est.. - Fini - Qui est fini
Mais du coup fallait pas arracher ça j'aurais pu le..
Mais t'as ouvert une chaîne cette année, une nouvelle chaîne qui s'appelle L'obèse
pour suivre tout ton parcours sur la perte de poids
où t'as déjà perdu plus de 20 kg, et c'est ouf
et la chaîne elle est, hop je tourne vers toi,
elle est ouf intéressante et y'a un truc que j'aime bien chez Mehdi
c'est ton flow, ta manière de parler, ton flow, je suppose qu'on te l'a déjà dit en fait
t'as une voix qui est cool à écouter, t'as une voix de radio même
- Ouais, c'est ce qu'on me dit souvent ouais, merci
Et du coup la chaîne moi je m'y suis mis assez rapidement, on se connaissait pas encore
des fois on se tweetait, je vous recommande d'aller voir la chaîne
je mettrai un lien ici et je mettrai un lien dans la description
Je vous fais pas le coup de "ouais abonnez vous c'est trop important et tout"
Allez voir, allez regarder une vidéo de L'obèse et vous risquez d'être surpris comme moi
mais faites juste ça, allez voir, déjà
- Bravo à toi aussi parce que t'es super impressionnant
- Merci
- C'est bizarre, vraiment sur place je vous dis c'est bizarre
- Il est dans ma tête, là actuellement il sait ce que je pense
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous aura plu
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner juste là avant de partir, c'est cool, parce que le MentalVlog
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er janvier au 31 décembre donc rendez-vous demain à 17h
Ciao